[Music]
Abell sockets Sammy lays down this
week's thoughtful Thursday video I
wanted to answer a question I get a lot
which is Samuel what books would you
recommend what books have served you as
a property investor and as a business
not the best so today I picked my top 12
books so of course you might call me
biased but these are two of them these
are these are both my books I've written
three books but as a property investor I
mean I think you would be an idiot not
to read these because not only are they
the best they're also really short and
really easy to read so do you like these
books that's the one that got me this is
the one that got you yeah so this book
made you what how many hundreds of
thousands two hundred thousand so there
we go costs 10 pounds 99 from Amazon got
him over 200 grand next this is called
don't sweat the small stuff again a
fantastic book really I think so many
people let the little things distract
them from the big thing so um what what
I do actually is every year I write down
my top four or five goals yeah most
people have it to do list every day
without you know hundreds of things on
it to do I wanna do that I'm stuff able
to do lists I've like four or five
things things yeah and that's all I
focus on and every time I do something
I'm thinking is this working towards
that don't let the small stuff get in
your way highly recommend read this book
next how many years ago did you read
this our tutors I'd you know my counting
gave me that in 2009 I think it was
either yeah brilliant business book if
you are wanting to systemize your what
any kind of business this is all about
systemization and we're placing yourself
working on your business but not in it
you've done this with your deal
packaging business setting you because
how you know you know I spend a day with
my deal packaging business uh sort of
David to means ever so you in the combi
days a month yeah couple days a month
for cover days a month and how much you
making thirty-five or forty thousand
thirty to forty thousand per month per
month
and that's because of the thickness
ization so and a lot of the stuff that I
teach has come out of this so I have to
really credit some of these behemoths
that brilliant book brilliant book for
systemization next I could not leave
this one out
bum bum bum Rich Dad Poor Dad this was
my first ever investment book that I
read it's brilliant yeah it's brilliant
you read this and then I think my book
came up as a suggestion
dead year so that I read that fast and
it came up you may like this also then
it was you look this books all about
passive income and really about
reconditioning your mind from some of
the old ways of thinking to actually
financial no financial freedom but
passive income and investments and not
having a job having money work for you
instead of you working for money we're
in book this is kind of like legendry
isn't it might even have to take I don't
know if this would take number one it's
certainly the most a lot of people that
come to my crash courses that have
started off bothering this books after
thank Robert Kiyosaki and I know we book
dinners with him and different things
like that nice bloke very very
knowledgeable very direct good bloke
like your sake gets a lot of it's a lot
of stick but I guess everyone gets stick
with there's you know direct like that
and you help that many people next
little voice master right you know where
you can have all of the knowledge and
you can have all of the training you can
have all of the money to invest you can
have everything going for you but if you
have those little voice if you listen to
those little voices in your head they'll
let you use them I have little devils on
my shoulder going crazy at me so yeah
what saying you can't do they're not for
you yeah it's somebody else's time it's
too good to be true
all these little voices well this does
it teaches you how to be aware of the
little fears and doubts and voices that
you have in your head and says that
you'll always have them but it's not
about it's not about killing the little
voices
it's about mastering them which is why
it's called little voice mastery by
blessing blessing is also a personal
friend of mine so I've been a lot of
Tommy Blair and he's a fantastic guy and
this book is just incredible so get this
from here my next week and you're not
read this yet I've not read all of it
I've read this
do it mate keep it as a gift gift gift
from me to you
alright this one's really important that
this one Alastair is not read how to win
friends and influence people tell that
he's not ready no you do have friends
I'm your friend you know what in quite
well I think I need to reread this
because this is really about how to get
what you want in life
yeah but but but get it without walking
over people without upsetting people
just kind of keep people on side having
friends but also influence it it's a
really really good book I haven't read
this in a long time I really should
reread this because I think I do offend
a lot of people and this might be a bit
more nice
you don't offend that many people well I
need to reread this but brilliant book
really good this really set me up for
life I read this about 10 years ago next
this yes there is a fantastic one 4-hour
workweek ironically it takes a lot more
than four hours to read the book I was
gonna disc it's quite a thing four hour
work week but it takes like 40 hours to
read it this is one thing I don't know
why Tim Ferriss spent so many words on
this book because although it's
fantastic it is it's a very exhaustive
read
I don't business I think there might be
a simplified version of this which might
take four hours to read however
fantastic and and what this early I know
you've implemented a lot of stuff but
some of this stuff you've got secondhand
form from me yeah yeah but but but this
really talks about how it doesn't take
that much time to get things done and
it's about saving time only focusing on
the important things
awesome awesome people Lily Dahle don't
they die instead of focusing on just
that cuts this short period of time yeah
I know you like you blast and you yeah
but a window will ya blast and do we got
to do yeah chill out and in blasted yeah
and surprisingly this is written for
employees so if you have a job this is
really gonna help you can escape the
nine-to-five live anywhere and join the
new rich because he talks how to get
your nine-to-five done in short time and
how to start getting your employer to
agree agree to you working from home mr.
flood that says really good book read
this
next one of my favorites great book it's
great that when I joined the Academy I
made you read they said yeah that was on
a book listed for nothing that was the
first one we have to read yeah yeah
one the Omni Academy we always try to
encourage people to read these books so
Jeff Olsen again I've met Jeff great guy
and this the slight edge basically talks
about the two become really successful
and become wealthy and to succeed as an
investor or businessperson or whatever
it's all about the little choices and
the obituaries in life so this will
really give you new habits like for
instance getting slim you know you don't
suddenly go on a a two-week fast they
get slimming and that you know what you
do is you just have you just change your
lifestyle habits and then you get slim
same with success say we probably same
everything brilliant book I read this 11
years ago do you know how to from that
book if you just do one little thing
every day yeah and in a year's time look
at the changes gonna happen yeah that's
what I tend to read this every few years
and this is one of my personal favorites
best ever best ever biography real easy
read I love easy reads screw it let's do
it this book I read when I was 16 years
old so now about what eleven twelve
years ago and again changed my life also
I know Richard Branson I've met him on
more than one occasion great guy
one of the most interesting bunch of
energy that you'll ever meet he's such a
nice guy as well auntie he talks about
if an opportunity comes along say yes
and then figure it out later
and this his life is a living testimony
of that what he's achieved is fantastic
he's probably one of the most loved and
well respected business people
entrepreneurs on the planet so you can
read this in probably a few hours so
absolutely inspirational and a really
refreshing read as well his life story
with a lot of lessons in there because
of that seem that Steen just say yes and
do it yeah I just say yes worry about
later
most people worry you know an
opportunity comes along and they're
worried about all the again a little
voice don't worry about what about this
one about this whereas he just goes for
it and yeah that's how he achieved so
much success I love Richard Branson next
we're almost there
eat that frog fantastic book time
management
is that critical yeah not met Brian
Tracy but I I I've heard him I've heard
these audios I've heard him speak yeah
I've listened to he does video series as
well about time management yeah I mean
eat that frog the idea is eating a frog
is obviously unpleasant so what is
talking about is do the most unpleasant
tasks first so when you wake up the
things that you like maybe phone the
estate agent or you know the things that
you normally would put off and you think
about if you think I need to do that at
some point you think about and you do
the jobs that you enjoy first and then
the really important ones that you don't
never get done see says just wake up in
the morning and the nasty jobs just eat
that frog or get it had the water but
not procrastinating not wasting like not
yeah billion things just get on with it
21 great ways to stop procrastinating
and get more done in less time really
good book I've only events twice but
it's fantastic and lastly this is
probably gonna be the best of all of
them and this is whatever it takes by
now there's dead coming up now in all
seriousness this is a fantastic book
you're apt to get in the top 12 not just
because you're sat next to me I've read
this again I've probably read this three
times and I know I brought the forward
yeah what's this book about it's about
my journey so it's about where it was 80
months ago to meet the new and to
personal battles and personal struggles
and to those sitting here on your phone
you and your front room not pretty much
you AMA so firm we all business partners
and we're very very good friends but not
only is it your story but it's also it's
very practical oh I've been talking
about how to set up as a compliant deal
you know yeah I was really practical I
was very conscious that didn't want it
been full of sort of filler and fluff
I literally a very direct person so bang
straight to the point
it's a fabulous book you can literally
read this book and start making money
straight away but the cool thing is
whatever it takes what a great title for
a book because all gianni if you want to
be successful
you got to be prepared to do whatever it
takes I completely agree so my advice to
you would be even if you just read like
I'm talking about slight edge
little and off them like you can't read
all of these books in one go it's gonna
take time but my advice will be just
start reading a chapter a day you know
just spend 20 minutes a day get up in
the morning and get up get up 20 minutes
earlier than you normally do and just
read 20 minutes of one of these books we
miss there's nothing so stay off
Facebook and just going you read a book
exalt like a and you know what rather
than filling your mind with what your
broke loser friends on Facebook put on
their newsfeed you know let's go through
that for 20 minutes why not just get up
in the morning and read like don't
there's any excuses that because like
most of these books are available
inaudible yeah so you can't turn your
car into a mini University 200 percent
you know so when you're when you're in
your car C is an opportunity oh great
I'm gonna be able to learn in the car
you know I think me I've read even for
short journeys yeah yeah I just come
from the offices to here it's like 25
minutes the average person spends about
ten hours a week driving oh well so if
you just every time you drive it listen
to audre listen to these books on
audible then within probably a year or
two you would have read it I'll tell you
away if you read every one of those
twelve books it would change a lot hmm
you get a different person man yeah so
it's just the small changes so but I
tell you what I love reading books but
there's nothing a lot of these authors
of met and I've been on their training
programs enough I like dinner we've done
and I just don't think you can beat live
training program there live interaction
because they've not only to get the
information but you get it in a fun way
and you can ask the author questions you
know so whatever you do get down to a
property investors crash course because
I have not only read hundreds and
hundreds of books but I've also spent
hundreds and hundreds of thousands of
pounds getting trained and everything I
now just the best if it comes out of the
Cross Allah sent me a narrated by Lauren
hi yeah and then that came that came
with an opportunity to come to the crash
course yeah and being there live is much
the bit was good it was great yeah I
actually been there live
it's like night things well then you
know
although reading is great yeah reading
books is fantastic I really recommend it
it
it's the bottom it's the absolute worst
way to learn yeah reading a book is the
worst
here's the order reading mmm hearing
yeah seeing seeing it done yeah then
doing it yeah and then the ultimate is
to teach teacher and that's why I love
teaching yeah I put up my programs of
the property investors crunch cause you
don't read it you don't read it you
don't hear it you actually see it that's
why I'm the crash course I do deals
mm-hmm but then I get the everyone in on
the program to do deals yeah and then I
get them to teach what they did and
explain back to me so it's almost like
learning on steroids because it probably
is most people most people won't spend
20 minutes a day no they will give up
one weekend
one weekend that will change your life
this is turning into a crash course Beit
Jala Frey you know what you know why
that is I'm so friggin passionate if it
comes back to the doing a little bit
like a slight edge doing that little bit
every day a little bit nothing
yeah it's nothing 10 15 20 minutes of
these attend one program one training
program every three months yeah or if it
was a quarter I mean you still good
training program yeah and I go to Lhasa
tree what's those in Germany right now
blessing up trying to use fantastic
because because the more you learn the
more you earn hundred and if you want to
be wealthy but you're a small container
you as you learn you grow and then you
you you you're your container grows and
you have an ability to hold more carry
more impact more be more yeah who was
either said if you're born broke that's
not your fault
but if you die broke that's your fault I
don't know it was it says it's been true
yeah and the way to not die broke is to
learn so I hope that was helpful if
there are books that should have been on
the list that were not on the list
comment them below favorite books also
your feedback and hope to see you on a
crash course we'll put a link below www
dot property - investors but credit UK
come on - across wasn't mean already and
see you next week on thoughtful Thursday
[Music]
you
[Music]